a powerful earthquake has struck central
croatia causing damage in several cities
including the capital zagreb
according to the european mediterranean
seismological center the magnitude 6.4
event struck some 50 kilometers
southeast of the capital
official reports say caused widespread
destruction collapsing roofs the facades
of buildings
and entire buildings the tremors also
prompted the precautionary shutdown of a
nuclear power plant
in neighbouring slovenia
we can go to uh daliwa dobrich who's in
zagreb welcome dalibor what are you
hearing
uh well the latest that we have
is that there is a confirmed one
fatality
in the town of petrinia where the
epicenter was
and also casualties uh in terms of
smaller wounds lacerations and so on
are reported in zagreb and other places
as well
croatia has experienced uh
four more earthquakes since the big one
which was at uh noon and and
uh 19 minutes uh local time
um strongest one was 4.5
so the the the earth is still shaking
uh the reports from the ground are that
uh there are collapsed buildings roofs
uh but it's very difficult to get
a clear uh picture of how how widespread
the
the the destruction is the prime
minister
uh went there straight away fire
departments from all over the country
are scrambling to get to the uh to that
area
the phone lines are jammed uh parts of
zagreb and i believe other parts of the
country are without electricity
and uh this was a very powerful
earthquake it it
lasted for longer than 20
seconds was frankly quite
horrible to to to experience uh it was
felt as far
as as split on the coast and and
zadar and rieka in slovenia and
even as far as belgrade in serbia
as you've been speaking we've been
looking at pictures of the scene there
uh
seeing organized evacuations as well as
volunteers helping or with the rescue
efforts this is the second
uh of uh and indeed more powerful
earthquake to hit in in
a couple of days and people there must
be must be uh
very concerned
uh i would say that that people are on
on on on edge of of of uh
breakdown uh yesterday's tremor
was um uh also in the same region of
petrinia which is some 50 kilometers
south of zagreb
uh but this is also a second major about
third
major earthquake that hit croatia in the
in this year
in march zagreb experienced a 5.5
uh earthquake which uh
there was one fatality and uh there was
a
massive destruction to the historic
center of the city
um so and since then uh we have recorded
more than 2000
smaller earthquakes measuring at
one or two on the richter scale
but so this is this is much of course
much larger much more
much more powerful a bigger destruction
but people have been
nervous and edgy about this uh from
before and now this is really
pushing them uh toward their limits
there are thousands and thousands of
people
uh crowding in the streets which of
course is considering the epidemic very
very not a very good thing um
out of fear of returning to their homes
all right well we we thank you for that
uh thanks for joining us dalibor
dobrich in zagreb
you